[Music]
hey how's it going bros my name is Pippa
today we're going to play my favorite
anime of all time Tokyo ghoul
I'm a real fan that's why I have the
attire so we're gonna play multiplayer I
will of course be my BAE my one and only
Levi
oh how I love you keep talking dirty to
me Levi I never played online before
this should be should be good a lot of
lot of players playing this game right
now a lot of a lot of anime fans how
about this one do you guys like anime I
love anime it's my favorite have you
guys seen Naruto I can hear that you
hear me why are you ignoring me hello
fellow anime fans why are you ignoring
me Hey only I can be Lee my fakers bow
come down dude you come down okay you
don't talk to me like that you don't
[ __ ] know me all right ah [ __ ] it
crashed with no man's sky outperforming
everyone's expectations this game really
it's not letting down hi fellow anime
friend [ __ ] what am I doing wrong here
welcome welcome
enemy friends police press X so we can
play together great let's go and attack
some Titans I have to warn you guys I
have at least 200 hours and experience
try to keep up we're gonna play sorry I
didn't catch that you were talking too
slow
[Music]
[ __ ] sake he crashes all the time it's
each duccini playable so if you're not
familiar with Tokyo ghoul it's basically
a bunch of Barbie dolls came together
and decided to a can't attack mankind
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna have to censor this
video now great is he just gonna look at
me
alright let's take out his legs I swear
I've seen a porno like this oh my god is
he just gonna stay like that he's like
well just come on just [ __ ] me what the
[ __ ] is he doing this game is absolutely
flawless is this some weird Titan techno
dance how gravity works okay don't worry
about it I gotta say the combat is
pretty awesome though I'm not gonna
laugh look at that [ __ ] went right
through his penis now the question that
we're all wondering where is potato girl
my favorite characters potato girl you
were right there sexual you can buy a
[ __ ] duster all my effort now in life
is to get that duster oh my god this guy
looks like at a facelift about 500 times
it seems like the game follows their
enemy very very carefully it's really
cool actually I always hated that guy's
haircut it's so [ __ ] annoying I feel
like I'm sporter mane instead of
shooting web a thrust aaron is so
[ __ ] overdramatic wow this game is so
good oh my god he destroyed my silence
and oh yeah you fought you you're done
don't ever [ __ ] touch my salad again
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh he got
the apples now you're really done it
Terrence now that's a sexy one okay wow
what a great threat
if you look too carefully the game is so
bad I mean there's no way that's gonna
get repetitive what's the [ __ ] am I
looking at what hey wait wait my friend
died thank you all I want is the Duster
that's all we're doing here committed
Esther give me the [ __ ] nasty ways
the Duster give me the desk oh my god
this guy is learning me the haircuts in
this enemy is just the best see I could
even do the voice acting look at this
yeah yeah oh so why are some of them
some skinny I need to know their diet I
guess actually nevermind I don't need to
know their diet Oh thumbnail I found it
look at that [ __ ] come on then put their
[ __ ] in then damn they're [ __ ]
flying around thing is really cool all
right you can't it's it's it's real cool
I can't help but being a little turned
on while playing this game I don't know
why oh my god he broke my house me cos
I'm more like Tsukasa am i right now
what the [ __ ] is that one doing the
thing that threatens our existence
despite its wonkiness though I gotta say
it's really cool to be part of the enemy
hey how y'all doin there buddy
you're mind if we come in and fist you
I love fester I should be the writer of
this show thank you very much I wonder
if this is confusing if you know don't
know anything about the anime it's like
why are all the naked people doing that
actually it doesn't make sense if you
watch the enemy as well yeah yes this is
all I want
just pretend you're a [ __ ] wall
it'll be okay Hey look there's me oh oh
oh I'm telling you they should use me
come on give me the distance
give me that [ __ ] justice I want the
justice oh it's time to clean up oh [ __ ]
he got me what the [ __ ] is that down
effect that's the sound effect you went
with okay you know what enough returning
to camp I think this game is pretty cool
despite despite its flowers if your
attack of the time and fan you will
definitely enjoy it and if you're not
you might say noon Deb yeah if you like
that's my official review thank you very
much yeah I like the game I hope you
enjoyed it too if you did leave a like
and I will see you on another video
episode love you guys so much so much
wait back I want my white face
I want my social awkwardness back game
[Music]